hi there Steve Kaufman here I just want
to announce that I hope to have a a
hangout tomorrow with Richard sim card
and Luke column perriello two of the
best known and most proficient polyglots
on the internet the timing is going to
be eight in the evening london time nine
in the evening Rome time which is 11 in
the morning here in Vancouver so if this
all works out if we manage to get
together for our hangout that means that
it will be broadcast on my youtube
channel youtube channel at that time and
then will become a video here youtube
and i believe that people can submit
questions although i'm not not entirely
sure and look at Richard and I will talk
about their recent in fact and my our
recent participation in the polyglot or
in the language conference in Moscow and
the preparations for this exciting
polyglot conference in Budapest that's
going to be next month not so far away
and which I gather is proceeding very
well with a lot of enthusiastic people
planning to be there unfortunately I
can't be there partly because I have to
be in Vienna in the beginning of june
and i didn't really want to hang around
for two weeks and i'm going to be in
vienna and then in romania which means
by the way that I'm going to start
studying Romanian it just so happens
that we have Romanian about to be
launched that link we discovered there
were some technical issues having to do
with some changes at the site which have
delayed us launching Romanian but thanks
to the hard work that mckaela put into
getting people to vote for romanian at
our facebook page he got over a thousand
votes so those were the conditions we
had set for adding a new language
because there's always problems with
adding
language and now we are in fact finding
that there's a problem and there's a
glitch and one of our collaborators in
st. Petersburg has to go in there and
somehow fix it so that we can add
another language but hopefully that will
be done within a day or two and so I'm
going to launch myself into Romanian and
when i visit romania on the fifth of
june where i have to go on business
because we have wood industry dealings
with Romania I hope to be able to at
least stumble around a bit in Romanian
we will see in any case the main subject
of this YouTube video is the fact that
we hope to have a hangout discussion
tomorrow with Luca and Richard once
again it's 11 a.m. pacific time which
would be 2 p.m. east coast north america
and 8pm or 20 hours in london and 21
hours or nine in the evening in Rome at
Google Plus hangout so I look forward to
seeing you then and by her out